the question of vaccines for children
has never been far away but as schools
return the government's vaccine advisors
have said no to jabs for younger
teenagers
i don't think it's a confusing decision
i think it's quite clear the risks and
benefits are finely balanced
but the other wider considerations such
as educational benefits need to be taken
into consideration before recommending
universal vaccination for well children
but lisa who's more vulnerable herself
to koben wants her children vaccinated
now
i've done founded really i've got no
idea how they've reached that conclusion
uh it seems like with a outlier again in
comparison with the rest of the world
france over 40 of eligible children have
been vaccinated millions done across
them across america
i i would i'd love to see the data um in
terms of educational disruption as well
i i have i've no idea how they've
reached that conclusion the joint
committee on vaccines and immunizations
main concern was a link to incredibly
rare cases of heart inflammation 200 000
more young teenagers with heart lung and
liver conditions will now be able to get
the vaccine but it hasn't been
recommended for healthy 12 to 15 year
olds
the chief medical officers are now going
to be looking at this issue of
vaccinating children and they'll look to
at the wider context so to give you a
sense of where we are with the data in
england around 1 in 70 people had
covered last week that's level with the
week before and you can see that in
scotland the number is one in 75. that
is a significant increase on the week
before and we're saying is the highest
level in scotland since estimates began
of course schools have been open there
for longer and if we compare that data
the data for england to where we were
last year you can see there is a stark
contrast remember this time last year
there were still local lockdowns we were
about to see in a few weeks a rule of
six coming back into force but the level
of infection now at the start of this
month is 28 times higher than last year
and that's before school start and
classrooms mix
increasing vaccination coverage
will have some effect on reducing
transmission
but
it's still really not clear how much
benefit
vaccinating that age group would have on
reducing transmission in society
the jcvi only look at health issues the
chief medical officers will now be
looking at the wider context like
disruption to education
they're expected to make their
recommendations within days and the
government will then have the final say
ali fortescue sky news